[Musique]
oui
le troisième cristal est très loin à
vichy au nord dans la forêt des elfes
sylvains il va falloir marcher longtemps
pour y arriver
oh merde fait chier [ __ ]
il nous faudrait des chaumes aux enfants
de bureau j'ai l'information vous
cherchiez le guide
c'est le type assis à cette table pas il
s'appelait sombres de l'âme
mais son vrai nom c'est sabrina seuls
mes amis m'appellent comme ça nous
sommes à la recherche de je ne sais pas
si je peux le prononcé du shit des
coques et speed et puisque ça nous avons
besoin d'un guide et vous serez pas revu
pour faire le jeune habitant année je
suis pas au but je suis un humain
pourquoi tes pieds nus alors ça mais
[ __ ] on a encore volé mes pompes
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
on
effet jamais mais pourquoi au cours
comme ça fait plus classe vous les plans
drôle craig c'était parce qu'on était
parti sans payer
oui monsieur [ __ ] de merde le soleil
va se coucher il faudrait se reposer
l'influenza ça remet d'attaqué comme en
ont grand temps que toi là je vous
propose de faire une halte afin de se
reposer
[Musique]
cela faisait des jours que l'on marchait
dans la forêt il fallait que l'on trouve
vite le gain no mercy et fallait que
l'on trouve le dernier cristal car le
pouvoir de l'enfant de lyon
être contenue éternelle
et nous revoilà pour parler des rpg on a
gratté la mère de coller au fond de la
poêle dans les deux premiers épisodes
mais on peut encore aller plus loin on a
déjà parlé de quelques rpg mauvais alors
évidemment il y en a tellement d'autres
qui sont mauvais mais hélas tellement
dont je pourrais pas vous parler
déjà parce qu'il me faudrait des mois
pour les finir mais surtout parce que ce
sont des rpg qui sont mauvais par leur
absence de gameplay leur côté vide ou
parce qu'ils sont chiants et c'est dur
de parler notre chien sans être chiant
justement donc c'est pour ça que ce coup
ci on va sortir des jeux distribués en
europe pour aller voir du côté du japon
et là messieurs les japonais vu la
qualité de votre jeu je vous met un
carton jaune rouge rouge stargazer sur
famicom sorti en 1987 au japon jamais
sorti en europe ce jeu est tellement nul
qu'il a gagné le titre de 17 sous noxon
gay c'est à dire jeu de merde légendaire
le jeu et en japonais évidemment donc je
vous montre là une version traduite donc
alors on peut considérer que c'est un
[ __ ] de match c'est qu'on ses
graphismes merde même naîtront
trouverais ça moche et attend des jeux
là je vous arrête tout de suite ah oui
on peut pas juger les graphismes des
jeux de cette époque non non en 1987
la console est sortie depuis cinq ans le
jeu est sorti d'album avec final fantasy
à ça c'est un arbre ça c'est de la merde
ça c'est une maison ça c'est de la merde
ça c'est de la pelouse et ça c'est de la
merde mais regardez ils sont faits
différente plus chier à le faire et au
final on dirait qu'un chien tourné le
gazon bon alors je suis rentré dans un
village notait d'ailleurs ce village
était particulièrement bien indiquée sur
la carte un sérieusement visiblement
quelque part dans le jeu j'ai lu qu'il
était marquée que le premier village est
cachée parce que les villageois
utilisent leur pouvoir pour le
dissimuler
[Musique]
mes couilles ou alors c'est un village
caché dans la forêt si on présuppose que
ce truc qui ressemble à des moisissures
en gros plans sont désarmants donc on a
là le peuple de la forêt de le sport
parce que oui c'est un jeu futuriste
j'avais oublié de dire ça mais tu es
sorti de la tête en passant devant le
mec qui a une barbe de merlin la ola et
roger ya plus dans ma boutique de
potions du futur bon donc bref le
village
[Musique]
mais c'est une blague
ma grand-mère marche plus vite que ça
elle est morte [ __ ] d'un super it
bleed le mec aller lentement mais c'est
seulement parce qu'ils étaient
encombrées là j'ai rien sur moi et j que
dalle comment tu pourquoi ils vont
justifier le scénario celle ci comme
pour le village invisible à l'udc est le
suivant sur les handicapés a été
supprimé car se moquer des handicapés ça
n'est pas drôle
enfin si c'est extrêmement drôle mais il
ne faut pas le faire
bon alors comme souvent dans les jrpg le
jeu va surtout consister à fermer de
l'argent et de l'xp comme un abruti en
restant pas trop loin du village pour
gagner des points de vie donc parlons un
peu des combats maintenant il se déroule
sur cette magnifique interface donc vous
avez là haut le s p qui permet de lancer
des attaques cixi c'est
ceux de la moche non c'est pas de la
magie c'est l'époux accents sensorielle
c'est le futur milieu extrêmement bien
fait si vous cliquez sur le s p mais que
vous n'avez pas de s p le jeu ne
contient aucune touche pour revenir en
arrière dans le menu et donc ça te fait
perdre tantôt sérieusement un jeu sans
retour arrière c'est même plus un bug
c'est le championnat du monde de la
branlette monsieur le jeu sort dans une
semaine et là que je retour arrière ne
marche toujours sur les toits bon ben
c'est pas ce que je voulais faire mais
ce serait bien
bon alors revenons au combat donc
ensuite vous avez freight pour attaquer
normalement et je précise que vous
n'avez aucune option pour fuir vous ne
pouvez pas fuir les combats
alors pourquoi pas aimé au moins adapté
les ennemis pour qu'il soit toujours à
mon niveau mais regarde cm qui me fait
32 dommage mais je suis en fait hein ça
semble évident l'équilibrage des
faiseurs pg mais ici c'est pas le cas
ma première partie ça ressemblait à ça
du coup à des bises et installe moi on
va vivre des avances mais ce jus plus
tellement la merde que je songe vraiment
m'en servir comme engrais pour faire
pousser des tomates
la seconde partie je tombe sur le
premier monstre il me pétrifie et je
peux plus jouer ça passe mon tour
automatiquement chaque fois que j'appuie
sur un bouton c'est incroyable j'ai pu
le droit de jouer ou alors celui là il
est immunisé à tous les dégâts ne marche
pas à la magie ne marche pas je peux
faire aucun dégât et je le redis mais je
ne peux pas fuir mais [ __ ] mais dans
ce cas là c'est bondé dimanche juste que
j'ai perdu mes témoins le game over un
suppôt et au lit quoi et non regarde là
le jeu continue chaque tour tu tape
dessus pour rien juste il essaye de
faire venir l'étincelle de l'espoir pour
mieux l'étouffer avec vos larmes
donc en supposant que je tombe pas sur
le truc dont je viens de parler
évidemment le but du jeu de tuer des
monstres ceci te permettent de gagner de
l'expérience et de l'argent argent qui
te permettra d'acheter ta première arme
le railgun au rayon laser armes qui est
moins puissante épée moins de dégâts que
tes points de base mais vous foutez de
ma gueule là c'est quoi cette merde
bordel ça fait une heure que je vous dis
que c'est un magasin de jouets ici
évidemment je peux pas l'enlever les
collégiens est maintenant mais c'est
trop bien mais c'est génial ce jeu me
voilà level 1 avec une arme nouvelle - 1
dans un jeu où je peux pas fuir les
combats qui sont une fois sur deux
contre des monstres qui ont 10 niveaux
de plus que moi voulait pas me jeter les
petits cailloux pendant je joue aussi
histoire de rajouter
bon donc sinon le but du jeu d'après le
texte du scénario et de trouver la
compétence eau qui seraient détenus par
un enfant prisonnier dans une cave
moi je les trouvais tout seul en tue un
lézard et cette compétence sous permet
comme son nom l'indiqué de marcher sur
l'eau et de traverser les murs et
évidemment et marche pas partout
là ça marche pas la wii la non non les
ronchons non non non non non à winnenden
oui oui oui non oui notamment winona oui
oui non qu'est ce qu'on se marre [ __ ]
pour résumer vous allez devoir marcher
sur chaque [ __ ] de carrés de chèques
[ __ ] d'écran de ce jeu pour savoir sur
lesquels vous pourrez marcher sur
lesquels vous pourrez pas tout ça pour
avancer et trouver les donjons qui en
plus comme le premier village n'est pas
indiquée sur la carte et donjons qui
sont par ailleurs aléatoire et qui
changent de place tout le temps jacques
bon pour relancer le jeu tient pas en
place dangereux et quand vous faites un
temps j'aurais bien quand vous en
ressentez vous êtes aussi pour aucune
[ __ ] de raison logique re téléporter
haut débit litigieux à côté du village
de départ ce qui fait aussi que des fois
que vous voulez aller quelque part
précisément que vous marchez
accidentellement sur un donjon parce
qu'il n'était pas indiquée sur la carte
quand vous ne ressentez vous êtes revenu
au début du jeu mais ce n'est pas grave
je ne suis pas énervé car je joue au rpg
et non pas pour leur gameplay et mais
pour leur scénario
tant que les scénarios et bien tout va
bien je sais c'est quoi le scénario
alors d'après la notice est un héros
avec des pouvoirs psychiques aidés par
des dauphins extraterrestre intelligent
et tu te bats contre un super
ordinateurs contrôlés par des orques
les orques les poissons à ceux qui
mangent des dauphins et c'est pas une
blague
[Musique]
sans pouvoir affecter de plus en plus le
pouvoir de l'entente de jurons devenait
de plus en plus instable que la bonne il
fallait que l'on trouve rapidement que
les stalles
sinon on finira tous comme cheikh guèye
un beau look et j'attendais je crois que
mes sens de cambrioleurs strictement
humain m'indique un danger imminent mais
[Musique]
ne bougeait plus sylvain fait attention
ne t'en fait pas un sylvain y est un
mois ce sont ici ils fussent ils font
baisser vos armes ce sont des amis je
suis silva fils de sylvain roi des elfes
cheikh impossible merde
et pourtant si les elfes ne sont pas des
créatures mystiques
non mais je veux dire c'est impossible
vous n'êtes pas un elfe j'avais même pas
aux oreilles sur le plan des tables
rondes à bahreïn
je souhaite vous aider dans votre quête
j'ai avec moi le jeu qui contient la
troisième je vous la donne
si vous me laissez vous accompagner
comme on dit dans mon peuple
in our man ray ban laissez moi vous
raconter une histoire car nous avons
voulu tester le prochain jeu nous
l'avons mis donc dans notre console dans
notre cd celle ci devant la colossale
odeur de merde qui se dégageait de ce
jeu a décidé de nous quitter
donc un petit peu saoulé d'avoir perdu
une console qui valait le prix d'une ps4
sachant que le marché des jeux rétro est
à peu près aussi cher maintenant que
celui de la vente de shit
nous décidons de partir à six heures de
route aller retour pour aller acheter
une nouvelle console tout ça alors que
je des malades avec 40 de fièvre
tout ça pour tripoter de mes mains un
des pires et trop coulant que le monde
des jeux vidéo n'est jamais connu ce
test ne sera pas effectif ok bon le jeu
fait
logibec depuis l'aube de l'humanité
l'homme l'a utilisé pour afficher des
images
bref bienvenue sur zelda adventure
troisième morceau de la triforce de la
honte sur cdi
on avait déjà parlé de l'igf il se fait
ville dans une ancienne vidéo et bien
maintenant on s'attaque au troisième jeu
qui est complètement différent des
autres puisque on quitte l'esthétique
vue de côté et dessins animés de merde
pour l'esthétique vue du dessus et
photoréalisme de merde ce qui est
vachement mieux je trouve partie donc
après une cinématique ou un vieux
poivrons avec une barbe vous explique
que link a été enlevé par ganon qui a
pris possession du royaume de tôle et
mac
et oui les rues le là enfin et c'est
quoi cette perruque acheté à la
foir'fouille la zelda et c'est quoi
cette qualité merde c'est pas le jeu qui
déconne j'ai vérifié vous arriviez bien
afficher une vidéo juste avant alors
pourquoi vous faites ça là c'est quoi
c'est un genre de show artistique mais
c'est complètement débile c'est comme si
je faisais ma vidéo normalement et que
l'image passés d'un coup comme ça le
sera à vous allez parce que mon pied
vous me le dites moi ça me prend moins
de boulot pour les prochaines fois un
bas à air va se calmer
tout va bien le jeu a même pas commencé
calme-toi allez on va créer la
sauvegarde
[Musique]
bon alors donc vous l'avez compris dans
ce jeu on dirige zelda qui ressemble
plus en plus du tué une serveuse de
bière dans une taverne en bavière qu'une
princesse du royaume et on commence au
milieu de rien pas de scénario que dalle
rien alors autant je peux accepter ça
dans un zelda un an 86 sur nes autant la
vente à [ __ ] on est en 94 donc va bien
te faire [ __ ] ce jeu fait moins bien
que la version game boy [ __ ] c'est
vraiment la honte quoi bon donc de ce
que j'ai compris le scénario lieu d'être
gano d'enlever zelda et link veulent
sauver ces gars n'ont relevé l'icg et
zelda va le sauver
original et oui donc vous voyez c'est ça
la touche phillips et l'excentricité
mais pas trop vous voyez aujourd'hui
j'ai mis mes chaussettes à l'envers je
suis partiellement fou
donc voilà le jeu voila voila contempler
donc le furoncle d'une des plus belles
sagas du jeu vidéo ce jeu simple le
cousin débile de la famille qu'on a tous
vous savez c'est un peu un zelda sur
lequel on aurait utilisé un aspirateur à
magie ce je te montre en fait à quel
point le monde de zelda serait glock
s'il existait andré déjà commencé la
musique il y en a plus voilà c'est
terminé la seule chose que vous
entendrez pendant la plupart du temps de
ce jeu sera ce [ __ ] de vent
bienvenue dans la réalité
prenez un siège alors ok on a des
limitations techniques j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il n'avait pas réussi
techniquement mettre de la musique et du
son en même temps mais ça pour le reste
est ce que l'explication pour laquelle
les araignées font un bruit de sangliers
ouais pourquoi est ce que les cailloux
font des offres qu'on leur tape dessus
parce que les rubis font un bruit de
cailloux pourquoi est ce que le sous une
dizaine et 6 nuls
non mais qu'est ce que le soudan design
non mais sérieusement qu'est ce que le
sound design je ne comprends pas ce rêve
après je me fous du jeu d'acteur alors
oui il est nul mais au moins juste
régler le son je vous jure que quand tu
joues sur une vraie télé à ce jeu les
scènes de dialogues ça donne ça
moi
et répète même pas leurs dialogues super
tu me files un objet mais vu que le son
est pourri j'ai rien entendu alors je
fais quoi tu veux plus me parler quand
je passe la souris dessus ça affiche
rien greenbuild dialogue merde à une
simple bulles de dialogue c'est trop
demander aux mêmes temps koné sur cet
écran ni thème de merde pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez pas fait un truc qui se
déplacent de case en case tout
simplement stockées devoir traverser
l'écran cette vitesse du coup voilà ce
que je dois faire que je veux changer un
item d'imposer la manette prendre la
télécommande chercher l'item que je veux
parce que pour dieu sait quelle raison
la télécommande va plus vite que la
manette puis reprendre la manette et
continuer le jeu je dois vraiment être
très très con ou beaucoup vous aimez
pour pas avoir tout j'étais dans une
cheminée déjà
surtout qu'on est loin d'avoir tout dit
dans ma lettre de suicide les temps de
chargement de ce jeu ils seront bien
placé aussi cette seconde
cette [ __ ] de secondes pour charger un
écran j'ai calculé écran qu'en plus tu
traverses en moins de 3 secondes pour
résumer sur une heure de jeu en réalité
tu passes 40 minutes a chargé un écran
et 15 à jouer et charges le temps
d'écran de merde j'ai envie de jouer moi
non j'ai pas envie en fait et c'est quoi
ces décors de merde nom de dieu
alors pour l'anecdote les développeurs
de ce jeu ont révélé qu'ils ont fait des
photos de leurs vacances perd lé décor
de ce jeu alors question cette partie ou
en vacances dans un [ __ ] de terrain
vague
bref ces jeux est comme un très longs
doigts dans ton cul le son est à chier
tu sais pas où aller tu ramasses des
objets de maire de moosch la regarde ça
c'est juste une [ __ ] d'image de bottes
décathlon qu'ils ont foutu en rouge
quoi tu le sens le moyen âge et la magie
là parce que moi là je sors la bretagne
et la pêche au thon dans quinze jours à
ça et les armes aussi quoi ça c'est un
boomerang qui revient pas c'est quoi
c'est un cintre en fait et ça c'est un
sai
c'est une arme de tortues ninja c'est
même plus justement ça a rien à [ __ ]
là et est ce que ce mec porte une
casquette une casquette ce mec est
complètement habillé comme un routier
sur une aire d'autoroute vous en aviez
tellement rien à branler à ce point là a
salué bienvenue aux ménages joue sans
qu'aucun borges bref allez parlons des
problèmes de gameplay événements j'ai
pris des notes
cet homme un jeu disait très vite dans
ce jeu tu commences à ramasser des armes
beaucoup beaucoup d'armes et chaque arme
coûte des rubis alors outre le fait que
des fois que des armes qui ont l'air de
faire exactement la même chose mais
c'est surtout que les armes consomme des
rubis rubis que tu gagnes sur les
monstres monstres qui ne réapparaisse
pas dans les donjons du coup et bien
comme un premier donjon comme le boss
est un peu costaud c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire
et que quand tu meurs tu réapparaît
juste devant lui je suis dans cette
situation ou n'ayant plus de rubis et
n'ayant plus de monstres à tuer pour
amasser des rubis seule solution
[Musique]
c'est incroyable de voir des aussi
grosse erreur quand tu sais que d'après
les interviews des développeurs ce jeu
est resté en test pendant deux ans ça a
été plus long de le tester que de le
développer vu que les développeurs du
jeu se barrer au fur et à mesure que le
jeu avance et ce jeu c'est un bon gros
tas de merde et chaque développeur s'est
succédé pour remettre une couche de
caramel dessus quand ça commence à
tropez et vous savez qu'ils mangent à la
fin c'est moi
1 le thème me voilà dans un village
[Musique]
non
m
ana
laissez moi rêver les passages dans les
villages c'est des moments qui m'ont
fait dire que les doubleurs de ce je
devais vraiment boire de l'huile de
moteur le matin au petit déj parce que
ok je me fous que les doublages soit un
peu nanar mais bon j'ai aussi mes
limites et même les quêtes n'est donc là
je dois acheter un os marchands alors
déjà pour acheter les items j'en profite
vous pensez que je vais juste marcher
dessus comme dans tous les zelda mais
bien sûr que non rappelez vous c'est
comme dans les autres et dallas sur cd
il faut se mettre devant l'item aller
dans les options sélectionnées les rubis
revenir à l'écran du jeu appuyé sur
attaquer pourquoi faire en deux secondes
ce qu'on peut faire en vain donc
cette quête je donne l'eau son chien et
le chien me donne une hache bercy
maintenant je peux rentrer sur notre la
bête et histoire de conclure en beauté
ces jeux est horriblement 2 pourquoi
parce que ça ta mère tout le temps ce
jeu test mes nerfs je compte plus le
nombre de centaines de fois où je suis
mort à la sortie d'un écran de
chargement de 10 en mer
c'est pas le truc à la sortie des écrans
c'est des trucs planqué dans les arbres
[ __ ] de doigts
ces arbres sont plus dangereux que les
pires boss du jeu nature de merde qui a
fait c'est une gueule de mort pour il a
le fantôme de l'opéra et saint-just qui
veut te détruire mentalement aussi
ce jeu qui n'a aucun recovery time vous
savez dans un jeu vidéo quand tu te fais
touché c'est ce petit en devenir
habilités ou ton personnage clignoter
pendant lequel qu'il peut pas reprendre
de coûts layana pas mais bon ouais ouais
voyez le bon côté des choses au moins ça
clignote d'ailleurs bon je pense bien
que les développeurs sont aperçus que
l'enjeu était de la grosse merde parce
que bon vous avez juste et vire fini les
gentils
[Musique]
non non c'est pas gentil vous êtes des
horribles connard monsieur notre jeu est
horrible dur frustrant et personne ne
s'amuse fait le dur et ça vaut aussi
pour les donjons attend ça c'est une
grotte
non mais pourquoi seulement une seule
[ __ ] de raison pour que ce trou
gigantesque dans le mur ne soit pas une
grotte merde et c'est une bonne saucisse
et id box
comment je le touche comment je touche
pas comment je les touche je suis
fatigué ce jeu et au rpg ce que dragon's
lair est au jeu de plateforme
c'est le pire mais s'étend à plus d'un
sultan qu'en plus je se torcher le cul
au passage avec la licence de zelda et
je parle de ce jeu alors je n'ai même
pas fait fait pour ça vous savez
pourquoi
parce que la console dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure les sauvegardes
ne marche
[Musique]
non mais un peu de charme le temps
depuis mon jeune âge elles ont disparu
ou sont en chambre il
hahaha
la boule introspectif dans le sud
[Musique]
regarder par terre oh mon dieu il s'est
fait entièrement dévoré sylvain où êtes
vous
répondez-nous quelqu'un nous a volé nos
j'aime à l'eau
il est là aux grandes ou les pierres de
pouvoir qu'on puisse rentrer dans le
château [ __ ]
[Musique]
j'aime le château un bond de plus long
terme
l'étrange personnage que l'enculé il ne
reste alors qu'elle seule solution
on pourrait les prendre par surprise et
jose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce passeport ou crème
merci
[Musique]
t'es pas obligé de faire ça sur ma mère
n'était pas obligé mais encore moins
chez moi et tu disais magie mais elles
se sont immunisés contre ce type de
magie vieux fous et voilà les amis
jalons battu le méchant libérer le
château la prophétie est désormais
accomplie le monde est maintenant rang
[Musique]
bon franchement ce paquet ouais
[ __ ] mais qu'est ce qu'ils foutent
j'espère qu'ils sont pas trompés de
châteaux non à ce sont des lignes en
cinq minutes mais j'ai une armée d'orgue
étant depuis deux ans dans la cour à un
bocal
j'ai deux garçons ces merdes à je t'aime
tant que dalle avec ses murs à la con
wifi noël
au calme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]